it's our opening monologue it's gonna
focus on two major points that was
brought up by Rush the king of talk
radio and they have to do with president
Trump's agenda the NFL the national
anthem controversy we're going to cover
all of that in tonight's Florida live
very important opening monologue so
today we traveled out of Florida to talk
with the leading conservative voice in
the country the one and only Rush
Limbaugh now that interview is coming up
later tonight but first we asked Rush
about Republicans in Washington and what
they must do to finally start passing
you the people's agenda the president's
agenda let's take a look this is the
deal I really believed that if for just
three months going forward or if they
had been three months in the past just
three months gut it up for three months
and work with Trump on his agenda on
cutting taxes seriously across the board
immigration reform the wall what have
you getting rid of Obamacare which is
just it's it's an absolute crime what
has happened here and what that's gonna
mean that they don't just just try for
three months make it look like there's
unity between the president of people
his own party and they would own
Washington for a generation Rush makes a
great point three months you know what
this isn't that difficult shouldn't be
that complicated and where's the
Republican vision in action on passing
the president's agenda
in other words where's their spine their
backbone in fighting for their
conservative principles and also where's
their honor their dignity to keep their
word their promises
so is repealing replacing Obamacare and
creating health care savings accounts
and health care cooperatives we've
discussed this on this program for years
cutting taxes cutting regulations energy
independence is it really that hard to
get done they've been promising they
would do these things for years and
years and by the way more importantly
where is this sense of urgency to help
the millions of forgotten men and women
in this country that we always talk
about help those people this is what the
election was all about and it's what we
tell you every single night 50 million
Americans in poverty on food stamps
you know what the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s right
now Republicans do need to unite three
months he talked about get the job done
now just take a look at how they did
come together earlier today when
congressman Steve Scalise when he
returned to the House floor for the
first time since that terrible shooting
you know what that's the type of unity
that Congress needs and it's going to
better serve the country now on the
topic of taxes President Trump did
unveil his plan yesterday for massive
cuts sweeping reform in the mold of
presidents Ronald Reagan and John F
Kennedy
now with those two former presidents did
it worked and we have decades of hard
evidence now to back it all up now back
in 1962 one year after I was born at the
Economic Club of New York then President
John F Kennedy he gave a speech about
cutting taxes and unleashing the
American economy Democrats in Congress
who oppose President Trump's plan maybe
you guys should pay close attention
because you have no agenda watch this
the final and best means of
strengthening demand among consumers and
business is to reduce the burden on
private income and the deterrence to
private initiative which are imposed by
our present tax system and this
administration pledged itself last
summer to an across-the-board
top-to-bottom cut in personal and
corporate income taxes to be enacted and
become effective in 1963 I'm not talking
about a quickie or a temporary tax cut
which would be more appropriate if a
recession were imminent nor am I talking
about giving the economy a mere shot in
the arm to ease some temporary complaint
Wow now President Kennedy he slashed the
top marginal tax rate from 90 to 77
percent and guess what happened the
economy soared millions of jobs were
created and revenue to the federal
government lower taxes it didn't go down
an increase and then when Ronald Wilson
Reagan came into office he started a tax
revolution that forever changed the
country by letting you the American
people keep more of your hard-earned
money now here's what President Reagan
said back in 1981 the first years
president if the tax cut
goes to you the American people in the
third year that money returned to you
won't be available to the Congress to
spend and that in my view is what this
whole controversy comes down to are you
entitled to the fruits of your own labor
or does government have some presumptive
right to spend and spend and spend in a
few days the Congress will stand at the
fork of two roads one road is all too
familiar to us it leads ultimately to
higher taxes it merely brings us full
circle back to the source of our
economic problems where the government
decides that it knows better than you
what should be done with your earnings
and in fact how you should conduct your
life the other Road promises to renew
the American spirit it's a road of hope
and opportunity it places the direction
of your life back in your hands where it
belongs and then during Reagan's
presidency he enacted historic tax cuts
and reform now let's take a look at this
Reagan slash the top marginal tax rate
from 70 to 28% in the course of his
presidency economic growth it took off
in a way America has not seen since in
1984 GDP hit 7.3 percent now compare
that to President Obama he was the first
president in history to never have an
entire year at even 3% GDP growth and on
top of all that Reagan created 20
million new jobs after the 1982
recession revenues to the government
again they doubled and America saw the
longest period of peacetime economic
growth now what Ronald Reagan did work
and it changed the trajectory of the
country forever now President Trump
modern day he's trying to do the same
thing now take a look at what the
president said while he was unveiling
his new tax plan yesterday what's this
this is a once in a generation
opportunity and I guess it's probably
something I could say that I'm very good
at I've been waiting for this for a long
time we're going to cut taxes for the
middle class make the tax code simpler
and more fair
for everyday Americans and we are going
to bring back the jobs and wealth that
have left our country and most people
thought left our country for good we
want tax reform that is pro-growth
pro-jobs pro worker pro-family and yes
tax reform that is pro-american and I'm
Democrats now they have no solutions
they're already coming out in full force
against President Trump's plan and
they're going to insist that any bill
that passes it has to soak the rich in
taxes but that's not what Reagan did and
what these obstructionist Democrats
won't tell you is this top-earning
Americans already pay way more than
their fair share for example the top 1%
of wage earners in the country they
contribute thirty nine point five
percent of personal federal income taxes
the top ten percent ten percent of
Americans they pay 70 point nine percent
now let's compare that the bottom fifty
percent of wage earners in America they
pay two point eight percent and there's
almost and this is a good fact that 35
percent of tax filers they pay zero zip
nada nothing
and by the way they'll pay even less
under President Trump's plan which of
course the media is not highlighting now
president Trump has momentum and growing
the economy which is why we need tax
reform you want to make it better we
want the engine to soar second quarter
GDP was just revised upwards 23.1% much
better than Obama compare that to him
the first president in history never
reached 3% GDP growth in a single year
of his presidency that's history pay
attention Kennedy Reagan Obama won one
side works one doesn't and since his
election presidents from he's worked
with all of these companies to bring
jobs back to America to help the
Forgotten men and women and the Trump
administration they have either pulled
or suspended 860 burdensome Obama era
regulations now like Rush was saying
earlier tonight putting the agenda in
place to fix the economy it shouldn't
take Republicans in Congress longer than
three months and unlike the rest of the
conspiracy theory fake news
out there you know what on this program
we made you a promise on Monday we are
interested in solutions we want to help
people
so to Congress tonight it's time to get
to work get the job done it's three
months of hard work serving the American
people isn't really that hard and also
tonight the fallout continues over some
in the NFL disrespecting our flag or
national anthem and of course our
military now I also asked rush this
interview coming up in a minute about
this controversy he's a huge NFL fan
take a look they're backtracking that
well this is not about protesting the
flag it's not about yeah of course it is
they try to save it that's how it all
got started if they really wanted to
make you think thinking if one of these
players are group of them called you and
said we want a half hour on your show
when you give it to them 100% why did
they do that
why are they messing around on the
sidelines disrespecting the flag
disrespecting the anthem what's the
point they're not accomplishing anything
except harming the enterprise whatever's
happening NFL right now it's not how you
grow it you know what that's a great
idea from Rush and as I said to him I'll
be more than happy all invite NFL
players coaches owners those who protest
the national anthem you're invited on
this show we'll give you an hour we'll
give you two hours three hours whatever
it takes and you know what we'll do a
town hall you want to fill up a football
stadium we'll even do that for you you
know what all of you can come all you
have to do is show up and by the way if
you're really interested in solving
problems and finding solutions for this
country then I think it's time that
we've got to talk about solutions and
you know what we can solve a lot of
problems let's talk about reducing
violence in places like Chicago let's
discuss ways to improve America's
horrific broken educational system one
of a conversation how about helping the
millions of people in this country who
have been left behind 13 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
Americans in poverty under Obama and we
doubled the national debt you know what
we don't need is people like the head
coach of the San Antonio Spurs
Gregg Popovich using this issue to try
and divide the country even further
don't believe me take a look at this
or country's an embarrassment in the
world there has to be an uncomfortable
element in the discourse for anything to
change you know whether it's LGBT
movement or you know women's suffrage
race it doesn't matter people have to be
made to feel uncomfortable and
especially white people because we're
comfortable we still have no clue of
what being born white means that really
helped the country now unfortunately
there are people like that and
especially on the Left they try to
exploit especially in this case the NFL
protests and a lot of people want to
advance a political agenda political
causes and as president Trump has said
repeatedly this comes down to simple
basic fundamental respect respect for
the flag respect for our anthem respect
for the military that fought under that
flag now the national anthem is
something it should bring every single
American together for some reason there
are people who are trying to now use it
to tear us apart